amid reports of a partial withdrawal of
russian troops the u.s president made a
previously unscheduled address at the
white house good afternoon while
repeating warnings of massive sanctions
should the invasion go ahead he also
noted the stated rushing willingness to
continue talks i agree
we should give the diplomacy every
chance to succeed
and i believe there are real ways to
address our respective security concerns
shortly after the white house press
secretary was asked how the u.s would
define diplomatic success it would be an
a de-escalation
a proven de-escalation at the border
of ukraine where the russians are
pulling back their troops
where they are making clear
to all to the global community to the
media to the public uh that they are not
invading ukraine and backing that up
with actions
the u.s ambassador at the united nations
appeared skeptical about reports of a
partial russian troop withdrawal we've
heard these reports just as as you have
but what we know is that russia still
has more than a hundred thousand troops
on the ukrainian border so the threat is
still there
russia's deputy ambassador told al
jazeera that there was a withdrawal
underway in accordance with a
long-standing plan as it was planned
after the exercises part of them are
being pulled back and the other part
will be pulled back after the completion
of exercises we said that from the very
beginning so nothing extraordinary
for the moment the diplomatic process
continues
but the key to success in the eyes of
the us and its nato allies
a visible and permanent withdrawal of
russian troops on the ground
mike hanna al jazeera washington